the federal reserve announces three
potential rate hikes next year joe biden
can't convince joe manchin to join his
suicide squad and nancy pelosi defends
insider trading for congress people i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let bigtech track what you do
anonymize your web browsing at
expressvpn.com
then we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first let me remind you that
going online without expressvpn it's
like using your smartphone without any
sort of protective case most of the time
you're probably okay and then there's
that one time where you're playing with
it in the bathroom and it falls in the
toilet and it's just it's just no good
you should be protecting all of your
technological devices not just
physically but also in terms of their
data every time you connect to an
unencrypted network in cafes hotels
airports etc your online data is not
secured any hacker on the same network
can gain access to and steal your
personal data we're talking passwords
financial details family secrets it
doesn't take much technical knowledge to
hack somebody some cheap hardware smart
12 euro could probably do it your data
is valuable hackers can make up to a
thousand bucks per person selling
personal information on the dark web why
is expressvpn well it's got that
encrypted tunnel it creates the secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet hackers can't steal your
sensitive data it's really easy to use
so one button to download one button to
fire up the app and you are good to go
it's really convenient it works on all
your devices so just protect yourself
the easy way secure your online data
today visit expressvpn.com
ben that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn dot com
slash ben you next for three months for
free expressvpn.com
ben well it looks as though the reality
of the financial situation
is beginning to sink in according to the
washington post the federal reserve made
its strongest move yet toward tackling
inflation on wednesday moving up the
timeline for what could be as many as
three interest rate hikes next year
three okay so if you're president of the
united states generally speaking the
last thing you want is the federal
reserve hiking interest rates right
before a midterm election that's pretty
much the worst thing that could happen
except for it happening in your re-elect
year yourself but when the federal
reserve hikes interest rates this makes
it more expensive for banks to take on
debt when banks can't take on debt they
can't lend to you at lower rates your
mortgage rates go up your loan rates go
up it means less velocity in terms of
the money flow in the economy well when
you've got inflation the federal reserve
of course has to raise those interest
rates because
you have price inflation and wage
inflation and inspiring spiraling out of
control people's savings are worth less
it's hard for people to actually get
commodities production is not keeping up
with demand and all the rest of this and
so the federal reserve has to cut back
on some of that to prevent these giant
bubbles from happening well the problem
is that the statistical ramifications of
that for the administration in power are
usually quite dire because whenever you
ramp up the interest rates they
generally work in inverse proportion to
the unemployment rates so usually when
you ramp up the interest rates that
means that if you're a small business
and you've been taking out loans you're
getting easy credit well now you have to
consider the fact that those loans are
more expensive that might mean you need
to cut back a little bit you might need
to lay some people off so typically
speaking you get a jump in unemployment
when you have a spike in interest rates
this is what happened in the early 1980s
if you look at the 1982 elections for
example the reagan administration
in 1982 there are a bunch of of interest
rate hikes and the interest rate hikes
at the very beginning from paul volcker
were intended
to create pain that was the goal right
the goal was to to drive the interest
rates down because we had stagflation
democrats picked up a seat in the
midterm elections in 1982
they they picked up one seat in the in
the senate and they picked up 26 seats
in the house and that was largely a
result of the interest rate hikes that
had happened before now by 1983 the
economy was booming again and the reason
that it was starting to boom again is
because those interest rate hikes had
brought
back into some sort of stasis the actual
economic growth rates right basically
the the real economic growth was allowed
to boom because ronald reagan cut
regulation and he cut taxes and and and
he lowered the interest rate so now the
money had a solid basis a solid footing
but joe biden isn't doing any of those
things so the likely outcome of this is
that you're going to see the interest
rates spike and when the interest rates
spike you are likely to see an increase
in the unemployment rate you're likely
to see a slowing economy and unlike the
reagan administration which was focused
in on making it easier to do business
while solidifying the dollar now you're
solidifying the dollar which means that
credit is less cheap but at the same
time you are also increasing regulation
and increasing taxes
so that is not a good recipe
it's a recipe for stagnation
joe biden by the way understands that
this is a recipe for stagnation this is
the part that boggles the mind when he
put out at the beginning of his
administration his forecast for the next
10 years of economic growth in the
united states he said we're going to get
heavy economic growth in the next two
years we've gotten some not nearly as
heavy as it should be and then he said
that we were going to be growing at like
1.6 1.7 a year that doesn't even outpace
inflation those are really really bad
rates
because joe biden knows exactly what he
he's doing
the federal reserve jumping in right now
it means that they've misread the tea
leaves they thought that the inflation
would not be this strong and now they
got a problem they have to ramp up the
the interest rates in order to tamp down
the inflation
jerome powell has completely abandoned
his talk about how this is a transitory
phenomenon based on supply chain
shortages and he said yesterday the
rapid price increases are going to
continue well into next year
bottlenecks and supply constraints are
limiting how quickly production can
respond to higher demand in the near
term
these problems have been larger and
longer lasting than anticipated
exacerbated by waves of the virus
as a result overall inflation is running
well above our two percent longer run
goal
and will likely continue to do so well
into next year
in fact
he said more than that he said there's a
real risk that inflation may be more
persistent the risk of higher inflation
becoming entrenched has certainly
increased i don't think it's high at
this moment but i think it's increased
and so according to the washington post
the fed has been holding off on cooling
down the economy in the hopes that the
vast economic supports would continue to
help the labor market grow the fed this
week reiterated that for now we'll keep
rates near zero until the labor market
hits policymakers threshold of maximum
employment well i mean i think we've
pretty much hit maximum employment
considering that we have some 10 million
open jobs and only 7 million people who
are willing to fill them right when you
have more people who are who are
you when you have more jobs available
than people who are looking for the work
that's kind of definitionally maximum
employment at this point one of the
problems of course for the
administration again is that the likely
outcome of ramping up the interest rates
is going to be a slowing economy again
this this typically happens
the fed has two mandates according to
the washington post keeping prices
stable and getting the economy to full
employment but combating inflation by
raising interest rates can slow job
market growth pell defended the fed
saying it was not behind the curve and
addressing the inflation but recent data
convinced him and others it was time for
a shift in policy yeah no bleep i mean
you guys had forecast that there was
gonna be like four five six percent
inflation this year instead it's showing
like nine percent the ten percent price
inflation this year
there's been notable progress in the job
market but again some four million jobs
are missing from the labor market
compared to the pre-covet days
pal is still trying to blame the
pandemic for this but again it's not
about the pandemic as we'll discuss in
short order it really is about the
insane reaction to the pandemic that we
have seen from our garbage policy makers
fed watchers are waiting to see how the
fed will decide if the full employment
threshold has been met before addressing
high inflation for example powell points
its labor force participation which has
been slow to recover
well maybe the reason it's been slow to
recover is because the government paid
people to stay home and then basically
trained people to stay home
pell says we don't have a strong labor
force participation recovery yet we may
not have it for some time at the same
time we have to make policy now
inflation is well above target this is
something we need to take into account
also the fed revealed new details on
speeding up the full winding down of its
vast asset purchase program to march as
opposed to its initial goal of mid-2022
feds want the taper of supports for the
financial system to end sooner so they
can better be prepared to raise interest
rates so they've been buying up all of
these assets and there's no reason for
them to be buying up all of these assets
at this point at this point
so all of this is uh is bad news for the
biden administration they're going to
try and spin it it's good news but it it
is a realization and an understanding
that the economy is inflated beyond all
recognition the federal reserve has to
step in and do something
okay but that's not stopping joe biden
from continuing to push really really
bad fiscal policy we'll get some more of
this in just one moment first let's talk
about your sleep quality so last night i
went to bed at a good hour and then my
wife had to wake us up very very early
for a doctor's appointment for one of
the kids well you know that means that i
really value the hours that i've got on
my mattress and that is why we need a
mattress made just for us we took a
two-minute sleep quiz from helix sleep
and they shipped us a mattress made just
for us everybody is unique helix knows
that they have several different
mattress models to choose from they have
soft medium and firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot mattress is great for
spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers helix
even has mattresses with specialized
cooling technology if you and your
family can never agree on the
temperature of the thermostat so if
you're looking for a mattress you take
the quiz you order the mattress your
mattress the mattress comes directly to
your doorstep for free
you don't need to go to a mattress store
again they've got a 10-year warranty you
can try it out for 100 nights risk-free
really there is nothing to lose you're
on everything to gain you're spending
eight hours of your life every night if
you're smart on a mattress and that
mattress better be good go to
helixsleep.com
take that two-minute sleep quiz the same
way we did they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life helix is
offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at
helixsleep.comtelixsleep.com
ben okay meanwhile you would think that
the administration if they were pursuing
something that remotely approached sort
of the reagan policies of the early 80s
where paul volcker was ramping up the
interest rates to cut down on inflation
you'd imagine that they would be seeking
to incentivize business to keep
investing that basically their goal
would be to say to the business
community listen the reason we're
ramping up the interest rates at this
point is in order to curb a runaway
inflationary spiral this is going to
provide you a more solid basis to tell
what demand actually looks like as
opposed to too many dollars chasing
after too few resources instead it'll be
the right number of dollars chasing
after resources you should continue to
invest because we're going to loosen the
regulation we're going to make it pay
less tax so if we're going to create
more risk on this end for businesses in
the form of less demand
in terms of dollars flowing through the
economy we're going to lower risk on
this end by taking away some of your tax
burden and taking away a regulatory
burden right that would be the deal and
that would create a solid growth rate in
the economy where it's not all fungible
and created magically by the government
that's not what obiden is doing instead
he's insisting that we regulate all of
these companies up to wazoo
right he has all of his
financial bureau bureaucrats honed in on
how do we regulate big businesses how do
we regulate the stock market how do we
regulate people and at the same time
he's saying we should raise taxes and
he's saying that we should spend more
and more and more money
on various social services which creates
an inflation of its own right inflation
can be created in a couple of ways and
one of them is the federal the is the
federal government essentially
borrowing money and then just spending
enormous sums of money that's not the
federal reserve doing direct
quantitative easing it is instead the
federal government borrowing lots of
money via the federal reserve and then
blowing it out that way to the citizenry
okay so joe biden is not stopping on all
of this
joe biden yesterday said that he is
still hoping to pass buildback better
better
they lie they say it's a two trillion
dollar bill it's not a five trillion
dollar bill they say that they hope to
push that through by christmas
and nancy pelosi for one is very
optimistic about all of this she says
you know if we pass bill back better
you're not gonna have to worry about
inflation you're not gonna have to worry
about anything we'll take care of all
your problems here's nancy pelosi a
clicking and a clacking away
it lowers cost it lowers cost of child
care it lowers cost of health care it
lowers cost of food it lowers costs in
so many ways that are essential to
america's working families the very
issues that people struggle over the
kitchen table to figure out how we're
going to pay the bills the very issues
very uh
frightening things that people have
trying to go to sleep at night how we're
going to pay the bills well build back
better helps you to do that
i know buildback better helps to inflate
the cost of virtually everything
including child care and when she talks
about child care she's saying we're
going to subsidize a particular type of
child care but we're not going to
subsidize another type of child care and
we're going to regulate it pretty
heavily so the cost of child care for a
lot of families who don't feel like
sending their kids to a government day
care center that cost is actually going
to rise pretty precipitously
meanwhile nancy pelosi continues to
praise biden and pretend that he's doing
an amazing job
we cannot have geriatric delusional
morons running the country it's just it
is not a good solution to our problem
like the level of incompetence
this is the thing that it
always boggles my mind it boggles my
mind if the levels of incompetence the
staggering levels of incompetence you
saw in government you saw in any other
area of life you would never delegate
power to the people in the other areas
of your life if you went to the doctor
and every time you went to the doctor
the doctor misdiagnosed you
and or provided for a surgery that made
you worse than you were before you would
stop going to that doctor
if you went to a lawyer and every time
you went to that lawyer you ended up in
jail you would not use that lawyer
anymore and yet you go to these
politicians
average iq 37
basically vegetables who spend all day
figuring out solutions to problems that
don't exist or solutions that make the
problem significantly worse
and you want to give them more power
your solution is to give nancy pelosi
and joe biden more by the way i feel
like this across the board is not just a
republican democrat thing why do you
want these people to have power over
your life the only person who you should
give power to is somebody who doesn't
want to use it the first rule for a
politician should be somebody who
doesn't want to be in politics because
if you want to be in politics this means
you want power over other people's lives
people should be reluctant about how
they gain power people should be
reluctant about how they use power
the only politician you can trust is one
who promises not to do anything or to
give power back to you but anybody who
claims they can solve your problems
nancy pelosi and joe biden do and by the
way how many republican politicians
they're lying to you they can't they
don't have the power to do this
a little bit of epistemic humility would
be a nice thing around here
frederick hayek famously wrote when it
came to economics and when you
centralize all power in in certain pairs
of hands what you are doing is you are
actually ending up with people with a
fraction of the knowledge of the
generalized market running the entire
thing right if you if you were to use
the sort of centralized economic system
of the soviet union you basically have
seven people in a room you have the
commissary the commissars who are
sitting together
at the top of the economy and they're
making the rules for everybody why
doesn't that work even if they're really
high iq because their level of knowledge
is not as great as the aggregate
knowledge of the entire society this is
true across politics why in the world
you would have a group of people who
could not run a popsicle stand figuring
out for everyone else how the economy is
going to run how your life is going to
run how you're going to take care of
your family
it is it is beyond comprehension
how about a little bit of humility about
the fact that there is a system that you
do not run and that no one runs and has
been running for hundreds of years in
terms of how people actually run
their individual lives and interact with
one another you don't control it and
attempting to rationalize that into a
set of rules whereby a group of of
elites is going to run everything using
the set of rules
it's it's a pursuit of stupidity it's
idiocy the famous philosopher michael
oakshott suggested that that to try and
and pretend that a group of rational
rules made up by a group of people
sitting in a room and and sort of
boiling it all down to paper
that those people are not capable of
grasping the complexities of the
universe you're not capable of no one is
capable of complexing of grasping the
complexities of of the economy of human
interactions and yet you want to
centralize all of that in the in the p
brains of people like nancy pelosi or
the misfiring neuronal connections of
joe biden i'll never understand it i
really will never understand it
we'll get to joe biden trying to ram
build that batter through in just one
second joe manchin is standing in the
way first
we know that you want a better night's
sleep i've already told you about your
mattress you need a great sheet on that
mattress and we're putting together your
entire bedding
plan right now here on this show you
don't just need a great mattress made
for you need a great set of shoes i'm
talking about the best set of sheets
bull and branch they are the best sheets
they are the sheets that my wife and i
use they're the sheets that we put on
our kids beds at night they're just
terrific and they get better with each
use bullet and branch sheets are
incredibly comfortable they're really
breathable and sometimes you buy a set
of sheets and it feels like kind of
sticky and like gripping your body like
it's it's kind of it kind of feels gross
not with bone branch bullet and branch
man it's like sleeping in the sheets
made from heavenly clouds that they're
just great husband and wife team scott
and missy tan and founded bowlin branch
to create a new standard in betting by
doing things the right way not the easy
way bowen branch holds themselves to
high standards across the board and you
can feel it it's not just their sheets
they do pillows bath towels robes as
well they've got signature hem sheets
those are the all-time bestseller first
of all they really fit the mattress
they're not like going to pop off and
your face ends up on the mattress you're
like
no it's not like that bowling brand
sheets fit the bed perfectly again super
comfortable get better with each wash
treat yourself and your loved ones to
the new standard embedding from bull and
branch their gifts come wrapped and
ready in their special holiday packaging
order by december 19th for guaranteed
delivery by christmas best deals of the
year going on right now from now until
december 23rd with promo code shapiro at
bullanbranch.com that's b-o-l-l and
branch.com promo code shapiro exclusions
may apply
alrighty so joe biden is trying to
convince joe manchin to go along with
bill back better and it is going
extremely poorly as it should because
joe manchin made this very clear he kept
saying it joe manchin
throughout this entire process he's felt
like an american tourist in china right
like the rude american tourist in china
where nobody speaks his language and so
he just says it louder and still nobody
speaks his language so he just says it
louder like where is the bathroom they
were like
no
don't understand he's like where is the
bath
this is what joe manchin has been doing
to the democrats and they refuse to
understand the difference in this
scenario is that joe manchin isn't the
rude tourist he's the only person
speaking the language with the rest of
the people it's the democrats who are
out of control so he keeps saying i'm
not spending this kind of money it's too
much money stop
and nancy was like maybe if we appeal to
him this way he'll do it and the media's
like maybe you know joe manchin maybe
he'll break the filibuster
and then joe biden's like associated
with the amtrak mccorman pop isn't it
you know guys your joe manchin in this
camera
and surprisingly joe manchin does
nothing joe manchin is like nah
i gotta get back on my house boat after
this and go back down to west virginia
where joe biden lost by one million
points
and where he's currently underwater by
like 40 points
and i've got to explain to those people
why i felt it was vital to vote for a
two trillion dollar bill minimum in a
time of massive inflation where my
people don't want this bill
so yeah they've run into an impasse
there's a shocker it's not shocking at
all by the way joe manchin's only hope
of staying in the senate is being the
democrat who stopped buildback better if
he's the democrat who voted for a bull
back better then he's just chuck schumer
in west virginia which means he's out of
a job
according to politico tensions are
boiling over as discussions about
finishing democrats 1.7 trillion
domestic spending bill drag on between
joe biden and joe manchin the
legislation looks increasingly likely to
stall over the impending holiday break
prompting biden himself to bemoan the
slow pace well the good news is that you
can always just tell joe biden that it's
the middle of may 2021 he'll believe you
mansion grew frustrated on wednesday
when questioned about whether he opposes
a provision in the bill to extend the
expanded child tax credit deeming those
queries bull
and denying then he wants to end the 300
monthly check many families receive for
children
that provision expires this month
democrats had hoped it would drive a
year-end deal instead biden and mansion
don't appear particularly close to
clinching anything manchin has suggested
pulling the child tax credit from the
bill
publicly manchin says he doesn't oppose
the tax credit he's just saying you
don't get to you know wrap it up in this
sandwich made of crap and then sell it
to me
the talks between biden and mansion have
been going very poorly they are far
apart the source said though manchester
united developed a warm report this year
and collaborated on several prominent
pieces of legislation the plotting pace
of the talks between the two joes is
straining their friendly relationship
frustration among the white house aides
with mansion is high and growing and
while biden likes mansion personally he
too has grown tired of the elongated
talks and will soon push him to make a
decision and support the legislation
according to two white house sources
yeah it's gonna work that's going to
work what's joe biden going to do he's
going to club joe mentioned be like
joe
gotta tell you man come on man it's time
to vote for for the billboard
and joe manchin is going to be like i
live in west virginia why would i do
that
i'm growing impatient
joseph mcmansion i'm i'm just i'm i'm
i'm very impatient he's like so i don't
care by the way you notice whose name
has completely fallen out of this
kristin cinema he could get mansion and
cinema still
would not vote for this
because it doesn't mean her test either
this is not just joe manchin
this is kirsten cinema
neither biden or mansion view the
likelihood this bill won't pass until
2022 is damaging to their relationship
or fatal to the legislation itself
manchin's friends in the senate say he's
not looking to tank biden's agenda they
may have different views about timing
it's less about whether than about when
and how much said senator tim kaine well
those would be rather large questions
right how much what's in the bill etc
like you think in a midterm election
year people are gonna be voting for this
you really like once we hit mids from
election year i'm sorry people are gonna
be a little distracted trying to save
their seats
so good luck with this
biden had a lengthy phone call with
mansion on monday again spoke to him on
tuesday asked how often he's talking to
biden mansion said on tuesday i'm just
waiting i'm not in charge
of course it's not just biden who's
pushing mansion senate majority leader
chuck schumer is coordinating with both
here's the thing chuck schumer is an
idiot he's a terrible majority leader
what chuck schumer really could do is he
could go back to joe biden and he could
say why don't we shift our specs a
little bit why don't we actually break
this bill down into a series of smaller
bills that would make it difficult for
republicans to vote against they keep
saying each constituent part of this
bill has 65 okay so why don't you break
it down into 65 approval bills and the
answer is because they can't get those
passed
they have to wrap it up this way because
if they don't wrap it up this way they
will not be able to cobble together the
progressives and the radical and the
moderates they won't be able to do it so
they have to wrap it up into a giant
omnibus package and they can't pass that
giant omnibus package so the only good
news here is that reality is starting to
hit the biden administration and they're
having a real problem
coming up with with answers on all of
this
but
the the answer that democrats
will eventually come up with when it
comes to all of this is they're just
going to get angry at the institutions
because when they don't get what they
want they just start attacking
everything else
so they're going to they have they've
already created a massive inflationary
bubble
now the federal reserve is going to
crack down on the inflation which is
going to ramp up the unemployment when
it ramps up the unemployment joe biden
is going to push harder on the inc let's
break the filibuster let's stack the
supreme court now let's change all the
institutions when they don't get what
they want the answer is to break the
system
and not just to break the system to
break private competitors in one second
we'll get to the apparently
new passion among democrats for cracking
down on cryptocurrency because what
they're afraid of is that the
alternative to the dollar being
manipulated by the central government
will be a non-manipulable form of
currency we'll get to that in just one
moment first let's talk about the fact
that as we say inflation is dominating
the country the cost of everything is
going up that includes rent but in the
future what you're going to be seeing as
the fed tapers is you're going to be
seeing rising interest rates on the
mortgages right mortgage rates are going
to go up when they go up you're going to
lose your chance to refinance your
mortgage that'd be a great way of saving
money right now right inflation's going
up so you need to save money and the
mortgage rates remain low so now it's an
excellent time to refinance you need to
check out my friends over at american
financing you'll get a free no pressure
mortgage review you can learn about
custom loans that fit your life better
from lower rates to shorter terms even
high interest debt consolidation they
can do all of it they're currently
saving customers up to a thousand bucks
a month they're helping many people skip
two mortgage payments why not see what
they can do for you give them a call at
866-721-3300 that's
866-721-3300 or visit
americanfinancing.net
nmls 182 334 nmls consumeraccess.org
again go check them out 866 721 3300 now
is an excellent time to refinance and
you're going to lose your opportunity if
you don't do it now head on over to
americanfinancing.net
to get started okay so
when you are in trouble you need to find
somebody else to attack
and it seems that the democrats have
found a couple of things to attack
thing number one is they are going to
attack private industry now you saw this
yesterday when shenzhaki was claiming
that inflationary spirals in meat and
oil were created by greed in private
industry not by bad government policy
well now it seems that that many of our
nation's foremost financial innovators
on the democratic side of the aisle or
at the federal reserve they're very
upset at the possibility that you might
take your money out of the system and
put it into something like bitcoin now
full disclosure i own bitcoin i own
ethereum i'm big advocates for both i
think the bitcoin is excellent i think
that the the possibility of a currency
that is not under the centralized
control of a government with its own
political priorities i think putting
some of your money there is a good idea
which is why i own bitcoin i think
ethereum which is attempting to cut down
on the banking system's
transaction costs by creating all sorts
of innovative new ways to create a
trustless financial system that that is
a good thing
and understand that the innovation that
bitcoin represents and that
a lot of decentralized finance
represents is a way to cut out the
middleman the reason that you go to a
bank is because banks verify your
transactions right you know that when
you put your money in a bank the bank is
going to be held accountable if the
money is gone right so you trust the
bank which is why you put your money in
the bank but that also means massive
transaction cost because every time you
run a credit card the credit card
company has to get in touch with the
middle man the middle man then has to
get in touch with the bank they're like
seven or eight companies involved in
every credit card transaction which is
why it takes two or three days for a
credit card transaction to actually
clear you know this if you own a
business that just because someone
swiped the credit card doesn't mean the
money is now in your account now the
money has to go all the way through the
system of verification in order for the
money to reach your account when it
comes to international transactions it
can take like a week for an
international transaction to clear when
it comes to decentralized finance these
transactions can clear like that very
very quickly and in areas of the world
particularly impoverished areas of the
world where you don't have a good
banking system if you're in afghanistan
you can't deposit your money in a bank
account because there are no banks
what bitcoin does what decentralized
finance allows is for you to have that
money digitally and transfer it
digitally instantaneously that's a very
good thing for the world and it cuts out
a lot of the transaction costs in the
middle the way that it does this is
through the blockchain right the
blockchain is a way of verifying
transactions because it basically has a
history of every transaction that has
happened
with blockchain
that verifies that these are real
transactions because everything is is
encoded and and what blockchain does
it's a way the way that you earn bitcoin
for example is by verifying transactions
when people talk about mining bitcoin
it's not somebody on a computer with a
pickaxe right what mining bitcoin means
is that you are you have an entire
computer system that is essentially
decrypting
all sorts of transactions and verifying
the transactions actually occurred this
is how you provide some sort of
stability in the transactional system
now the drawback for bitcoin or ethereum
or any of these other cryptocurrencies
is that if somebody were to get your
password they can take all of your money
right whereas that is not true with bank
however that just means make a better
password right don't be an idiot and
don't use the same password for all of
your stuff and don't forget your
password right that but the the
attraction of crypto is that it cuts out
the banking system the attraction of
crypto is that it creates a trustless
system in which you don't have to trust
the person that you're transacting with
and you also don't have to trust a bank
to keep your money
right the the blockchain itself is the
trust because it is verified right
okay that that is that is the attraction
of it the other attraction of it is that
you don't have a centralized government
that is going to inflate the currency
where you put your money in a bank and
then you just wait for the government to
inflate it out of existence right if you
took 100 and you put it in the bank
at a zero percent interest rate just to
make the math easy back in like 1980 and
then you took that hundred dollars out
of the bank today it'll be worth like i
don't know 50 bucks 60 bucks maybe
okay so like the inflation rates eat
away at savings this is not true with
bitcoin and when you buy bitcoin
or any other form of crypto that is
worth its salt then what you are
actually doing is you are buying a value
that is not
dependent on infusions of money into the
system
right so that is the attraction of
bitcoin
and then there are things called stable
coins which are pegged to for example
the value of the united states dollar
right so you can buy a digital form of
currency that cuts out the transaction
cost and is pegged to the price of the
dollar
and so you would think this is a good
thing right there's a good alternative
and it takes enormous amounts of power
away from the government this is why the
government is so scared crapless of
cryptocurrency they are scared so
crapless of it that you are going to
stop like if if cryptocurrency ever
became a denomination in use
not denominated in dollars but things
started to be denominated in bitcoin or
you started trading in bitcoin it's not
stable enough right now for people to
really trade in bitcoin is one of the
problems with bitcoin is that it used to
be that there was this concept that
bitcoin would be used in transactions
right instead of paying for a car in
dollars you pay for it in bitcoin the
problem is because bitcoin is still
volatile because not enough people buy
it
and use it because of that the price of
a bitcoin could go up or down so if you
sell a car for
a bitcoin and bitcoin is worth 30 000
today so you're selling car for 30 grand
tomorrow that bitcoin could be worth 20
000 and so you just lost 10 000 bucks
right so this is the problem with
bitcoin but it's going to get more
stable over time as there is more and
more buy-in the government is so scared
of this stuff they are so scared of this
stuff they're afraid that they are no
longer going to be able to control your
monetary future they're paralyzed in
fear from this stuff so you have jerome
powell over at the federal reserve it is
amazing to me that we are willing to
trust people who are actively
manipulating the money supply in the
united states who i mean this is
literally their job it is not as though
they are hiding the ball they actively
acknowledge that what they do every day
is manipulate how much your savings are
worth
and yet we're supposed to trust them but
not trust a trustless system verified by
blockchain here's jerome powell ripping
on bitcoin
in terms of um
you know the more uh the
cryptocurrencies uh you know that are
really speculative assets
uh i don't see them as a financial
stability concern
at the moment
i do think they are risky they're not
backed by anything and um
uh i think there's a big consumer uh
consumer issues for consumers who may or
may not understand what they're getting
and they're certainly
um
developments in the in the markets that
are worth following which are really not
in our jurisdiction but things like you
know the kind of leverage that that's
built into and those sorts of things is
certainly worth worth watching
oh they're not backed by anything really
so what is the united states dollar
backed by
what is it backed by it used to be
backed by gold not backed by gold
anymore it's backed by the full faith
and credit of the united states which is
solid as long as you trust the united
states it's solid as long as you trust
the united states government
well you know what's one thing that
undermines trust in the full faith and
credit of the united states
one of those things would be a massive
national debt that is eventually going
to come to eat up a huge percentage of
our gdp every year and make it nearly
impossible for us to continue to operate
as a free economy without massive rates
of taxation or massive cuts to social
services
and full faith and credit of the united
states like the question is which do you
trust more a decentralized system where
no one controls it or a centralized
system where jerome powell controls it
and the full faith and credit of the
united states which is being blown out
on a daily basis
at a certain point there will be another
country that gets wise lowers its
corporate tax rate to 10 and just eats
everybody's lunch
truly i mean that will be like the
notion that the united states has to
lead the world in terms of in terms of
sort of the economy it doesn't have to
but we're a massive country that gives
us
certain advantages and we have 340
million people in it we have this huge
territorial grasp but that doesn't mean
that if we spend ourselves into oblivion
there won't be somebody else who comes
and eats our lunch right we are
benefiting from the fact that the
chinese government for example has
embraced the stupidest form of economics
in terms of communism then they moved
into a sort of mercantilism that's also
a dumb form of economics which is why
their outsized growth statistics are
rooted in the fact that they started
from a really really low baseline
basically everyone in china had zero
dollars and everybody in china has five
dollars and so they've had a massive
growth rate that does not mean that
china's per capita gdp is anywhere near
on par with western europe or with the
united states the per capita gdp in in
china right now is still really pretty
low the per capita gdp in china right
now is about 10 500 bucks per year so
all of the talk about how the the
chinese communist
regime has created massive prosperity
and china's not true they just have a
billion and a half people however that
does not mean that there could not be a
country that comes up and realizes that
all of the regulatory structures the
united states has set up are garbage
that our tax structures are garbage joe
biden has pushed a global 15 corporate
tax rate if there were a country that
went to 10
corporate tax rate they would just suck
in investors from everywhere the amount
of money that would flow in if you could
guarantee property rights and a
predictable legal regime in a state with
10 corporate tax rates that place would
eat our lunch within a decade it is it
is truly that simple
okay but unfortunately the uh
at the same time these people are saying
you should trust the full faith and
credit of the united states and you
should crack down on bitcoin elizabeth
warren is doing the same thing right
she's saying decentralized finance is
really bad because it allows for illegal
transactions oh what does cash do what
is it also you know it's one thing that
has allowed for massive illegal
transactions
a government-based banking system that
has essentially created massive
incentives to bail out companies who
take bad risks
i mean seriously what is more dangerous
to the to the stability and health of
the world economy truly what's more
dangerous the fact that some people use
decentralized finance to do drug deals
or the fact that every time there's a
financial crisis the taxpayers honor are
on the hook for trillions of dollars
which one seems more risky to you here's
elizabeth warren ripping on crypto
however
defy is the most dangerous part of the
crypto world this is where the
regulation is effectively absent and no
surprise
it's where the scammers and the cheats
and the swindlers mix among part-time
investors and first-time crypto traders
shoot in defy someone can't even tell if
they're dealing with a terrorist
stable coins provide the lifeblood of
the d5 ecosystem in d5 people need
stable coins to trade between different
coins to trade derivatives to lend and
borrow money all outside the regulated
banking system
without stable coins defy comes to a
halt
okay so without elizabeth warren
overlooking a financial system you
should be scared now with elizabeth
warren overlooking the financial system
you should be scared again why would you
give these people power why why why why
why and the answer is they want the
power of course they desperately want
the power which is why they're now
pushing against that they're also
pushing against the institutions it is
not a coincidence that the the same day
that elizabeth warren is calling for a
crackdown on on decentralized finance
she's also calling for court packing in
the pages of the boston globe these
people don't care about institutions
they care about power and mainly they
care about their own power we'll get to
nancy pelosi and an amazing statement
that you made yesterday with regard to
members of congress and insiders rating
we'll get to that in a moment the the
rules apply to the little bit you're
supposed to trust them to run your
financial future they get to insider
trade we'll get to that in just one
moment first the right now over 10
million job openings in the united
states but only 7.6 million unemployed
job seekers that issue is being worsened
due to a mismatch of employers in
qualified talent employers are having to
go above and beyond to entice people to
want to work for them now they're
offering like legal services or id theft
protection or pet insurance well if you
can relate to any of these challenges of
trying to grow your team and i'm talking
to employers every day
looking for people to work you need to
try ziprecruiter right now you can try
it for free at ziprecruiter.com
dailywire zip recruiter uses powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job then it
proactively presents these candidates to
you you can easily review these
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply for your job that
encourages them to apply faster no
wonder zip recruiter is the number one
rated hiring site in the united states
based on g2 ratings zipper cruise
technology is so effective that four out
of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the very first day and right now you can
try zip recruiter for free at this
exclusive web address zip recruiter dot
com slash daily wire that's
ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e zip zip-recorder is
indeed the smartest way to hire now
before we go any further here's a
reminder this company the daily wire we
were ready day one to challenge the
biden administration's unconstitutional
vax mandate and we are getting very
close to a million signatures on our do
not comply petition and we're getting
very very close because people are
recognizing that they need to sound off
and we're going to get to all the
coveted craziness right now democrats
are considering news shutdowns and all
this you have to resist you have to push
back this is what we are doing right now
with our petition we have a goal of
reaching a million signatures as i've
said we have over 875 000 signatures we
want to finish this before the end of
the year get to a million signatures
before the end of the year please if you
haven't already sign the petition at
dailywire.com
do not comply and then share our
petition with everybody like far and
wide we can get to a million let's send
a message so loud the biden
administration can't ignore us hey also
i am truly pumped about this okay we
have a brand new series available
exclusively at dailywire
if you've ever wanted to be a fly on the
wall for my conversations with my
closest and most influential friends
you're gonna love this like seriously
this is what this is i get to hang out
with all my friends and you're gonna see
what our conversations are like usually
when the cameras are off in the premiere
episode jordan peterson joined me for
coffee while he was visiting nashville
and we have i would say a unique and
pretty awesome conversation
all righty so i'm here in nashville with
jordan peterson jordan's spending a lot
of time in nashville in fact i think
jordan may know nashville better than i
do last night you dragged me to robert's
western world and you were like you were
like the the guy of the house like they
all knew you no no luke macquarie was
the guy the house the guitarist playing
the guitar
yeah kelly's heroes they're a deadly
band
i will say i feel like i was a little
more dressed for it like i was wearing a
t-shirt and a a leather jacket and you
were wearing this yeah you pretty much i
didn't have my kobe boots i haven't
bought them yet i'll get a cardboard
combo
exactly
it was really fun being there with you
oh yeah i know that that was awesome
you're a classically trained violinist i
am yes and and you like the music oh
yeah and i love that stuff i mean if
you're a good musician you're a good
musician yeah yeah
they really know how to play
sunday special is a lot more formal i
mean i'm coming in with with questions
and it's much less of kind of a
discussion between the two of us and
it's much more of kind of just me
probing and jordan's ideas but this is
much more like how we talk normally i
mean jordan you called me we talked on
the phone like a month ago and this was
basically the same conversation right
this is how we talk about different
topics but yeah different topics but i
mean like this is this is how we talk
when the cameras aren't on us people
really love being in on those
conversations
yeah no i i think that the fact that
people are going to kind of get the the
kind of the fly on the wall view of this
kind of conversation is pretty awesome
so you'll be able to see clips of my
conversation with jordan here at the
coffee shop on youtube but if you want
to see the whole conversation which
really is the way you should see it you
need to head on over to dailywire.com or
check us out on the daily wire app
you'll be able to see the whole thing
there and it's it's pretty fantastic
so go check that out my conversation
with jordan peterson drops tomorrow at
dailywire.com if you're not a member yet
now is the perfect time to send i'm
gonna do a bunch of these i mean this is
really how it works like i have a bunch
of really interesting friends and i talk
with all of them off of the air and then
we do shows where we're very formal and
i sit there and i interview them like
it's inside the actors studio this isn't
that what this is is how we talk when we
talk about our kids we talk about our
families we talk about our wives it gets
very intimate and it gets really deep
and profound it's it's pretty it's
pretty mind-boggling honestly like one
of the great aspects of my life is that
i get to talk to the most interesting
high iq people on the planet like off
camera and pride but now we wanted to
put that on camera so you can enjoy
those conversations too because honestly
some of the best conversations you have
are the casual conversations over coffee
head on over to dailywear.com subscribe
sign up today they're great you're gonna
love them you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
alrighty so meanwhile nancy pelosi again
these are the people you want to lead
you i'm not going to stop saying this
stop asking these people to lead you
they are corrupt they don't care about
you they care about their own power
they've convinced themselves they care
about you okay i'm not saying they're
not sincere i'm seeing them delusional
they are sincere they sincerely believe
that they are helping you it just so
happens they help themselves around the
edges a little bit too i mean
it does it really matter i mean if you
are they just have to take a taste just
a little taste so nancy pelosi yesterday
jews asked about members of congress
trading individual stocks now i'm of the
belief that once you're in congress you
should not be able to trade on the
information that you receive in congress
okay because if we are going to bar
insider trading for private entities we
should bar insider trading for members
of congress that's because they can in
fact even if you were to allow insider
trading for people in in the private
sector which again i think there's a
kind of libertarian case for that it
actually allows for free flow of
information more free flow of
information
for market response than there otherwise
would be right people actually get
information faster when insider trading
is available but put that aside if
you're a member of congress and you can
actually control policy knowing that you
can get a majority to
do a thing that is going to impact
business in a particular way so you
short sell the business or you know that
a business is about to get a subsidy
because you know it's been formulating
behind closed doors and you control the
system
and so you're using the power of a
democracy to make yourself more rich
that's super duper corrupt nancy pelosi
was asked about this yesterday she of
course has a long history of
questionable insider trading issues and
she was like well we are
we have a free market system hearing
marxist leaning nancy pelosi talk about
what a wonderful free market system we
are by utilizing government power to
make herself richer is uh pretty vomit
inducing here we go
should members of congress and their
spouses be banned from trading
individual stocks while serving in
congress no i don't know to the second
one um
any uh we have a responsibility to
report
in the stock
on the stock but i don't i'm not
familiar with that five-month review but
if
people aren't reporting they should be
because this is a free market in people
where a free market economy they should
be able to participate in that
that's not the question the question is
whether you're participating in a free
market economy or whether you you are
using your regulatory power to get rich
if you're a soviet commissar and you can
dictate
the price of shoes and so you go abroad
and you buy a bunch of shoes and you
sell them in the soviet economy while
dictating the price that is not a free
market and if you're a member of
congress and you're using your
regulatory power to subsidize or crack
down on a particular business and then
you are trading in that business at the
same time that is unbelievably corrupt
that is not free market stuff
this has been a long-standing issue with
congress
peter schweitzer has been has been
writing on this for years and years and
years all the way back in 2012 he talked
about congressional corruption newsweek
wrote about it
while examining trades made around the
time of the 2003 medicare overall peter
schweitzer experienced what he called
his holy crap moment according to
newsweek the legislation which created a
new prescription drug entitlement
promised to be a huge boon to the
pharmaceutical industry and savvy
investors in the capital among those
with special insight on the issue is
massachusetts senator john kerry
chairman of the health subcommittee of
the finance committee kerry is one of
the wealthiest members of the senate
heavily invested in the stock market as
the final version of the drug program
neared approval one that did not include
limits on the price of drugs brokers for
kerry and his wife were busy trading in
big pharma schweitzer found they
completed 111 stock transactions of
pharmaceutical companies in 2003 103 of
which were buys they were all great
picks schweitzer notes that carries
capital gains on the transactions or at
least half a million dollars and as high
as 2 million dollars
it was instructed to schweitzer that
kerry didn't try to shape legislation to
benefit his portfolio the key was that
he knew exactly what the government was
about to do and then he and then he
spent money in order to make money from
it
kerry's spokesperson said senator kerry
does not buy sell or trade stocks she
noted that carrie's holdings were in
family trust managed by independent
trustees further kerry was not a
beneficiary of teresa heinz carey's
trust which were established before they
were married also kerry was running for
president mitch missed much of the
debate but schweitzer says it's not that
i think john kerry is calling up his
broker on health care and saying buy the
company sell the company the issue is
one of a double standard he notes that
if the executive of a healthcare company
were in discussions with the white house
over pending legislation that would
affect his industry and then made a
bunch of unusual stock transactions
related to the industry the sec would
probably open an insider trading
investigation
says the only group in america we exempt
as politicians who are probably the last
people about whom we should be saying oh
we'll take their word for it that's
what's so amazing to me
okay and this has been a major issue for
years and years and years and years a
bipartisan issue by the way members of
congress who are benefiting from this
sort of insider trading of course nancy
pelosi thinks that that's the free
market
because according to nancy pelosi
using government money to do things she
wants is the free market
and then these are the people that you
trust with you like are you getting the
benefit of their bargain are you really
and meanwhile speaking of nancy pelosi
and her delusional policies she made a
statement yesterday that's just insane
she's talking about rising crime in
america's major cities
and uh the speaker of the house she said
there's an attitude of lawlessness in
our country and i don't know where it's
coming from
do you not do you not know nancy pelosi
because i feel like you do or you're
completely adult and the moths have made
their home directly in the center of
your medulla oblongata here we go
the fact is that there is an attitude of
uh uh lawlessness in our country that
springs from i don't know where
maybe you do
uh no i do i do it's from you
it's from you and your friends green
lighting rioting all of last year you
and your wildly liberal george soros
best prosecutorial friends who have
decided they are going to undermine law
enforcement throughout the united states
like i i know and i think nancy pelosi
does too reality is starting to hit home
for this crew and when it hits it is
going to be ugly so they have two
choices they can burrow deeper into the
delusion or they can realize that joe
manchin is kind of right they can
realize that
that they've undermined the full faith
and credit of the united states they can
they can recom they can recognize that
they've destroyed their own economic
hubs because of their coveted insanity
and through crime right they can
recognize all this or they can just keep
doubling down oddly enough some of them
are starting to recognize it and it's
very weird so for example san francisco
mayor london breed who's a nut in london
breed backs to defund the police
movement five seconds ago
and according to daley wire
speaking at a press conference on
tuesday breed erupted at the surging
crime around san francisco
here's what london breed had to say
this time
that the reign of criminals who are
destroying our city it is time for it to
come to an end
and it comes to an end
when we take the steps
to be more aggressive
with law enforcement more aggressive
with the changes in our policies
and less tolerant
of all the bulk that has destroyed our
city
we are going to turn this around
i mean
she is one of the chief manufacturers of
the bull
like that's a that's a weird take
so i'm glad that she's come around to
this it is weird to see rudy giuliani
inhabit the body of a black woman that's
strange and she's just talking and all
of a sudden she's morphed into rudy
giuliani talking about cutting down on
crime it's unbelievable
it's
you know if you see the morphing
happening in real time so bizarre maybe
reality is starting to hit because as of
last year she tried to divert 100
million dollars from the san francisco
police department to social justice
programs so yeah reality is starting to
hit
so the question for the democrats is how
fast it hits because maybe the democrats
can pull their chest nuts out of the
fire for 2022 if they allow reality to
intervene but it seems like they're not
going to allow reality to intervene it
seems like they are they are focused in
like a laser beam
on not allowing reality to intervene
on any of these subjects
right a little bit on crime maybe
although eric adams swore in the new
nypd commissioner in front of a of a
mural that included actual cop killers
which is a strange move by eric adams
yesterday in new york still it seems
like in some of the major cities
the chickens are coming home to roost a
little bit for democrats nationally
however they've i think they're going to
have to get wallop first honestly i
think the democrats are going to have to
lose an election they're going to have
to lose it in a massive fashion
what's so ironic about all this is that
joe biden was supposed to be the guy who
was still steeped in reality
he was supposed to be the guy when he
was elected who's going to be moderate
who's going to have both feet on the
ground who's not going to run after the
radical proposals of his base and
instead he decided to go as radical as
humanly possible it is truly amazing and
he's still doing it yesterday joe biden
was talking about
kovid
and he's just like ripping on freedom
like openly ripping on freedom it's
pretty amazing
everybody talks about freedom and not to
have a to have a shot or have a test
well guess what and so how about
patriotism how about making sure that
you're vaccinated so you do not spread
the disease to anybody else what about
that
what's the big deal okay so first of all
what he's saying right there what he's
saying right there is inaccurate if
you're vaccinated you can in fact spread
the disease to other people according to
his own cdc he's contradicting his own
cdc but the more important statement he
makes there is what about freedom i hear
all these people talking about freedom
what about what about patriotism what
about patriotism a little bit it's like
well
joe your definition of patriotism so far
as i'm aware consists in
giving up afghanistan to the taliban
paying higher taxes
destroying businesses allowing crime to
run rampant in your cities and taking
shots this is the definition of
patriotism according to joe biden good
luck with this message truly i hope that
you run on this in 2022 i hope you run
on this message in 2024 it seems like
his definition of patriotism runs
directly counter to the message of
freedom those two are supposed to work
in tandem in the united states to be
free and to be patriotic are supposed to
be things that work together in the
united states for joe biden they work in
direct opposition which suggests that he
is neither free nor patriotic it
suggests that he doesn't understand the
foundational principles of the united
states in other countries patriotism
runs directly counter to freedom in the
united states they're not supposed to
run against each other
but joe biden has a different idea if he
has any ideas at all left rattling
around up there alrighty we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of content in the meantime please head
on over to dailywire.com do not comply
we're at almost 900 000 signatures on
our do not comply petition and check out
the michael knowles show today he'll be
talking about some wacky protesting from
high school and middle school girls in
oregon the daily wire has been
exclusively reporting on that you can
hear more about that story over on
michael's show that's available right
now i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
ron desantis introduces the stop woke
act in florida vladimir putin tries to
rebuild the soviet union and high school
girls protest sexualization by taking
off their clothes at school bold
strategy we will see how it plays out
for them check it out on the michael
knowles show